so let's return to our top story now the
election of Labour's Sadiq Khan as
London mayor his victory makes him the
first directly elected Muslim mayor of a
big western city he says he hopes he
will inspire more Muslims to enter
mainstream politics well let's speak now
to Naveen Hussain the founder of British
Muslim youth afternoon - first of all
your reaction to his appointment
I think the appointment of Sadiq Khan
has been something which has been
celebrated not just by Muslims but
people from other minorities and for all
Londoners actually as something which
Sadiq Khan himself has said it has been
a victory of hope over fear a victory of
unity over division especially with the
type of campaign the dog was so horrific
brutish and bordering Islamophobic
campaign that was sadly run by Linton
Crosby and as that Goldsmith in this
election so that is great to see that
hopers try hope has succeeded and we've
had a mayoral candidate who so happens
to be a Muslim what is important is that
Sadiq Khan wasn't elected for being a
Muslim but he was elected because him
being a Muslim didn't matter to people
his policies mattered his ideas mattered
and his ideals mattered
that's what we've seen yesterday and
actually a burpee that was one thing I
was going to say to you religion is
irrelevant to the job of Mayor of London
and we don't say a Christian minister
has been appointed we don't say a
Catholic Police Commissioner has been
appointed why is it that it is
constantly being described as a Muslim
has won the election for London man well
one of the things that this actually
does do it takes away this narrative
that Muslims don't integrate you know
especially this year we've seen Nadia
Husain baking for the Queen and winning
the Great British Bake Off we've seen
riyad mahrez the Leicester City
midfielder win the Premier League
football of the year and the Premier
League title we've seen Molly Abu et you
know become the head of the National
Union of Students and which Sadiq Sadiq
Khan now becoming the London Mayor what
we can see is that Muslims are not only
integrating but because of the fact that
Zac Goldsmith actually running this
campaign actually made it important that
the
was somehow a Muslim as somebody who was
had links to extremism and you know it
takes away this idea that being Muslim
is just something individual for so many
people and it has nothing to do with
their job or the actions actually do
them but but but in the course of all of
that and obviously the Conservatives
would deny some of the accusations that
have been cast their way but during that
we also had the anti-semitic route
within the Labor Party so it's been a
dark time can I suggest vote for all of
politics a hundred percent and rightly
so I think there there was needed a
campaign and an inquiry into
anti-semitism within the Labor Party we
really need to look at these kinds of
issues because no type of hate and
bigotry can be accepted but I think the
Conservatives now have to also look at
their campaign was that Goldsmith and
actually I would actually ask for an
inquiry to be led as many Muslims as
many people within the conservative
ranks and outside the ranks are asking
for an inquiry to look at Islamophobia
within the minority within within the
Conservative Party but one thing I will
say is for the cons it doesn't end here
because tonight we have Aamir Khan seen
for Britain and hopefully he will become
the WBC middleweight champion of the
world as well okay that fight taking
place in Las Vegas this evening we
appreciate your time Levine Hussein
thank you very much you're welcome